This is how people celebrate
the Lunar New Year in Daly Village.
This year's celebration
is particularly special.
The adults around this table
all work in factories in the cities.
This is the only time
when many of them can see their children,
China's zero COVID policy over the last
three years has made it all even harder.
The people here are warm and inviting
people here.
They're so friendly.
I was just walking by and they're like,
Come join us for lunch.
We came to this place in China,
Southern Guedes O Province to help.
A part of rural China
is celebrating the Lunar New Year
without pandemic restrictions.
This village is nestled
deep within the mountains.
Its remote hard to access
because of that.
For hundreds of years
since the villagers have settled here,
the majority of the food
they eat, they either grow
or they raise themselves.
We visited villagers home.
Sanjaya greets us with a treat
and alcohol,
both made from rice
from the paddy fields nearby gourmet
drinking is a big part
of celebrating here. Not go
and Sanjay is popular in this village.
The door is barely closed.
Relatives stream in to use this machine.
The poor
and the freshly baked sticky rice.
It turns into paste.
Her machine is a novelty here.
Before they had to pound the rice by hand
with sticks for hours,
About 1000 people live in this village.
And for hundreds of years, they've lived
in these traditional wooden houses.
And you can hear the chickens crowing
and there are these ducks as well
that they raise for food.
In many ways,
this place is like a time capsule.
Its physical isolation
has preserved their way of life
for centuries.
Through China's dong ethnic minority.
They have their own language,
tradition and culture,
but they can't escape
the economic realities of modernity.
Normally,
this village is full of the elderly
and young kids
with most of the working age adults gone,
working in faraway factories,
sending money home.
It's only for these few days
during the Lunar New Year holiday
when they can really all be together.
We came across this migrant worker
who's just returned from
Jiangxi province,
more than 600 miles away.
This is a job, he told me.
He's brought some oranges
and candies for his son
and traveled for more than a day to
get home by bus.
This couple works in
a factory
500 miles away in Guangdong Province,
making circuit boards
Wow.
hate when the parents are away,
their grandparents take care of the kids.
This is common in rural China.
for the first time in three years,
millions of Chinese migrant families
are finally able to reunite without
the fear of COVID lockdowns.
I try
to find out if
this village's remoteness
has shielded it
in any way from the country's
sweeping wave of COVID cases and deaths.
It's all Asia.
Almost everyone
I speak to on
camera says no, one around
them has gotten COVID
like this elderly woman
who makes traditional crafts.
But we run into another group
of young people who say otherwise.
The man in the brown
jacket with his back
turned is a doctor at a hospital
in a nearby city.
So we've got the
three government minders following us.
A group of six government
minders greeted us
the moment we arrived in the village.
It's common for local officials
to keep a close eye
on foreign journalists
in their jurisdictions,
especially persistent in this village,
following our every move.
So we just wrapped up the interview
and one of the government
minders is sitting out over there
and immediately.
At least four of them
booked rooms in our same hotel or nearby.
So we drive out of the village
to visit
a public hospital
in a neighboring county
about 2 hours away,
hoping these government minders
won't follow us
so people will feel more comfortable
speaking freely.
We walk inside the fever clinic.
It's almost entirely empty.
In the main
hospital area, there are more people,
but it's not packed.
It's a stark contrast to the images
of overflowing
hospitals in major cities
across China for weeks before
I ask a nurse
on another floor of the hospital
if it was packed with patients
a few weeks ago.
She says it's always packed
and busy here.
We try to ask why it looks empty here.
But another doctor
interrupts, ending our interview.
We find one woman,
a patient's family member,
who is willing to speak to us
Soon after we realized
we're being followed,
apparently by a whole different crew,
there's at least two
or three government minders.
They are still following us
all the way here.
It's very obvious
they follow us to hospital
after hospital, preventing anyone
from speaking to us.
I try confronting them,
Are you thinking, Karl, now
he's walking away.
And what happens next?
During my interview, with this girl
shocks us.
Okay, so I interviewing the girl,
and then the minders literally
took her away from us.
The man pushes the girl
and her family away,
then later leaves them alone.
But her interviews
in the marketplace are over.
China's CDC says the COVID peak across
the country has passed.
But in rural areas like this, experts say
there's likely far more silent suffering
people who died at home
because they couldn't
afford to go to the hospital
or were unable to get there on time.
Back in
the village were greeted
by the sound of squealing pigs
getting ready to be slaughtered.
It's a Lunar New Year tradition.
Some of the families
raised the pigs themselves.
Others buy them from sellers
like this woman,
who tells me that
now that people can gather
and barbecue together.
Her business is booming.
Decades ago for
most countryside families.
This was the only time of the year
when they could afford to eat meat.
Now talk about bringing the family
together to feast.
So this is a whole family of relatives
are all getting together
for the Lunar New Year,
enjoying that freshly killed pigmeat.
Sanjaya teaches me
how they dress and do their hair
for special occasions,
showing me
all the clothes and fabric in her home
that she's made herself sewing.
Just a thin strip of this cloth
takes her more than a day.
But the mothers here
tell me they don't expect their kids
to carry on all of the traditions.
One of Sandy's
relatives, a young woman
who works at a cosmetics factory
600 miles away in Guangdong,
invites us to her home
Her parents and grandparents are proud
she sends most of her earnings
back to them,
whether it's in the village
or in faraway factories.
They're hardworking people.
They'll do whatever it takes
to give their kids a better life,
even if it means long about separation
from them.
Making reunions like these
all the more meaningful.
Selina Wang, Daily Village.
Guedes in China